It's great to be joined today by Nick Majali,
who's the CEO at Ritholtz Wealth Management
and also founder of Dollars and Data, a data
focused personal finance blog.
I've been reading Nick's articles for a long
time, and it's great to have you on, Nick.
Thanks, Dave.
Appreciate it.
So, OK, to start with, I want to talk about
the Biden tax plan a little bit and what the
implications would be, how likely it is to
happen.
But before we even get into that as a general
principle, when we look at the stock market
based on presidential terms, my personal analysis
is that the stock market tends to return a
higher tends to see a higher return under
Democratic presidents than Republican presidents.
It's not an overwhelming difference.
So the first question is, is that distinction
relevant to presidential policy?
I do not think it is I think most of that
stuff, when you really look at the data, there's
a lot of noise in there.
And there was like, obviously, you're right
that Democratic presidents tend to have a
slightly higher return, but it's also kind
of biased by certain things.
You think about Hoover and it was like a Great
Depression.
So that kind of messed things up.
You think about it which time period you want
to do.
Clinton probably has the best returns ever,
and that was the 90s.
So like there's all these outliers that kind
of move things around a little bit.
And of course, presidents do affect policy,
which affects markets.
I don't think it's as linked as we think.
I mean, probably a lot more noise, unfortunately.
Would it be fair to say then that the argument
you sometimes hear from the right that the
stock market is a disaster during Democratic
presidents?
That certainly isn't true.
Yeah, I don't think that's true.
I think that the same is also true on the
other side on the disaster turned Democratic.
I think that's all just political talk coming
out.
One of the interesting things that you write
in your recent article about the Biden tax
plan is that there certainly is an impact
on one's personal finances and networth from
presidents, but that it often has much more
to do with tax policy than it does with the
ups and downs of the stock market.
And that's a really important thing to understand.
So when you start looking at what the economy
might be like from a personal finance standpoint,
are you focusing actually more on tax policy
than expected stock stock market movement?
Yeah, I mean, for like free for you and I
and for most people, like what how tax policy
changes is going to affect the dollars coming
into your accounts and how much dollars you
have to pay out to the government.
And that's going to have a much bigger impact
than, you know, how the market might necessarily
react.
And of course, it's one of those things you
can't really know.
But I know tax policy for sure changes people's
decisions and behavior in a much bigger way
than I think just some minor moves in the
stock market.
Well, so let's talk a little bit about the
Biden tax plan.
When we did a dove into it a few weeks ago,
some of the notable things were the change
to the corporate income tax rate going from
twenty one to twenty eight percent, repealing
the Trump tax cuts.
And you would see long term cap gains rates
go from about twenty four to close to 40 percent.
You'd see that top marginal tax rate go up.
I think it's about three points to the pre
Trump era.
And then and then very importantly right now,
Social Security taxes stop at about one hundred
and thirty thousand dollars in income roughly.
I don't I know that's not exactly right.
The Biden proposal would then reinstate that
twelve point four percent tax from four hundred
thousand dollars and up completely uncapped,
which if done, is a massive amount of revenue
for for the government to start with.
Is it accurate that those under four hundred
thousand dollars a year in income will not
see an increase, which has been a big topic
of political debate?
They should not see an increase in income
tax.
Now, there are if everything in the plan went
through, there are certain ways in which,
for example, if you're getting property, if
you're inheriting property, you may have to
pay taxes on that.
If there's unrealized gains that you wouldn't
have had to pay in the in the current state
of the world.
So no income tax is going to be increased
on those people.
But you might see other types of taxes show
up given other life events.
As I said, if you're inheriting property specifically,
that's one that's going to be very relevant.
And with that property inheritance scenario,
is that based on the size of the estate or
it could be regardless of the size of the
estate.
So so there's a little bit of both.
So the estate tax right now allows for eleven
point million, one point six million for a
single person or twenty three point two for
a couple.
You can pass on no estate tax.
And then there's also something called stepped
up basis.
What that means is, let's say, you know, your
grandparents had a stock and they bought Apple
in like, you know, nineteen ninety five or
whatever, and now it's got a million dollars
in gains.
They can when they die, they can pass that
on to their heirs.
No taxes owed on the gain.
But if they get rid of that rule, anyone,
regardless of who you are, you get that you're
going to have to pay the tax on the difference.
And that's also true of real estate, among
other things.
Now, I don't think that's actually going to
pass.
There's a lot of talk, a lot of tax professionals
about this like that.
There's no way stepped up pace is going to
be completely gotten rid of because it's a
very complex thing.
I think the reason they use it to get rid
of stepped up basis is because it's just simpler
not to have to track how you improve the real
estate property for over 40 years and every
single home repair and then try and track
the basis of that is a nightmare for from
the IRS and for individuals.
So that's why they just kind of wipe it clean.
It's just a little bit easier that way.
So I want to talk about the likelihood of
any of these different things passing now
to even start that conversation.
If Democrats don't take control of the Senate
with a 50 50 tie by getting the two Georgia
runoffs, having Kamala Harris as the tie breaking
vote, does any of this stuff pass or is this
all I mean?
Is tax reform even getting done without a
Democratic Senate?
Yeah, so I don't think it's going to get to
I mean, even if they pass this.
No, here's that, here's the thing, even if
they do get you know, they won the two Georgia
Senate races, Kamala Harris, you know, cast
the tie breaking vote, you still have to,
like, argue for all these things.
This is like the wish list.
All these different things are the wish list.
But what's going to happen is they're going
to go back and forth with Republicans and
even there will be some Democrats who say,
I don't want to eliminate this or I don't
want to do this.
So this is really like the best case scenario
just to start.
And they're going to bargain in.
Some of these things are going to come and
go.
And I think, for example, stepped up basis
will probably be one of the things, if I had
to guess, that gets kicked out first.
So even so, for now, still continuing the
scenario where Democrats do have the Senate,
but there's negotiation.
I have a really hard time imagining that Social
Security will be uncapped from 400000 and
up.
And the reason I say that without making any
moral judgment about it is that is millions
and tens of millions of dollars in taxes for
for a lot of people.
And of course, part of it can be avoided by
not earning income through wages.
And we know about the way that that that can
be done.
I don't know how that gets passed.
Even the Democratic Senate.
Yeah, that's a good point.
I think.
Yeah, you're right.
In terms of kind of people will just immediately
companies like your new salary cap is four
hundred thousand dollars and we're going to
pay you all this extra extra equity income
for this extra thing.
They're going to find ways to get money to
you in ways that are not classified as labor
income.
Now, I think some people are probably still
just going to take the hit and like, OK, you
know, the employers take six percent, had
to pay six percent or whatever.
But, yeah, a lot of people are going to shift
salaries around.
And just like, oh, there's be the 400 K Club
out there to the Bronx that.
So what's the most reliable way?
I have sometimes financial advisors who will
write to me or they'll call into my show and
they'll say, you know, we already know that
just increase increasing income tax rates
is not a great way to capture necessarily
more revenue because a lot of really wealthy
people are not earning through wages.
So then you've got to maybe look at capital
gains.
But then there's also different ways to avoid
paying capital gains taxes.
Or you can always just kind of wait it out
because with capital gains, a lot of it has
to do with when are you realizing the gain?
And if you don't like what you would pay,
now you can wait for a different administration
in your experience, like if the government
was determined, we want to capture more of
the different types of income that people
are making.
What would be the most sort of ironclad way
to do it?
I don't know, that's a great question.
I think this is the question that's like everyone's
trying to figure out how do you curb inequality?
Really, that's really the question.
How do you curb inequality?
And someone's like, OK, we can just raise
capital gains.
Like, well, let's say let's say the you know,
the probability of this whole thing happening
where Democrats take over the Senate, let's
say it's like a ninety five percent chance
right now, predict it's putting it like twenty
four point five percent.
There's a one in four chance right now.
Let's say it was ninety five percent.
What you're going to see is people start realizing
the gains.
Now they're going to start going through.
There was even this thing where in 2010 think
the estate tax was like zero and a surprisingly
large number of people happened to die that
year.
So it's like people literally changed their
lives and somehow just accept the grave to
avoid taxes.
So I don't know what's the best way to do
that.
I wish I had a better answer for you.
Like you can do things like that.
People have tried wealth taxes, but that's
like on the really, really rich people.
But that's talk like how do you determine,
well, how do you capture that, prevent people
from fleeing?
There's all sorts of ways to get at this.
I think it's really difficult.
I mean, capital gains are a start, but it
depends how big the jump is.
I mean, a twenty three point eight to thirty
nine point six percent is a big jump, and
that's going to change people's behavior if
that were to happen.
So then going to the next scenario, which
is Democrats don't get the Senate, is there
any tax reform getting done in the next two
years if Democrats don't get the Senate?
I don't think so.
I mean, we're ending gridlock.
I mean, I'm obviously not an expert at that
thing, but I don't see how it's going to happen
out.
Republicans, if they can prevent it from happening,
they're happy with what's going on right now.
So I think we'll just have more of the same.
So for the average person who makes an average
salary, maybe has access to some kind of matching
contribution, if they're in education, maybe
it's a 403 B or a 401K.
You know, with our staff, we do a simple IRA,
average person, a normal person.
Does it make any sense to be making any changes
to what you are doing on the basis of who
is in the White House?
I would say no, definitely not.
I mean, going back to our earlier discussion,
like, you know, markets rise, markets fall
under any sort of president.
You can look through history like they have
drawdowns.
Twenty, thirty percent drawdowns.
Almost every single president and markets
go up during almost every president.
I mean, there's obviously exceptions, you
know, but I don't think it's the president's
fault that, you know, we have hyperinflation
and we have this or that.
Like, I don't think it's necessarily always
the president's fault for that type of thing.
You know, even when FDR took over in the Great
Depression, like initially, like, there was
a lot of hope.
But still, the economy was sluggish for a
while and finally got back together.
So when the coronavirus when the initial coronavirus
dip happened in sort of like mid-March, the
Internet was riddled with hot takes about
cell now or by more options or weighed by
back in in a month, this sort of stuff.
Now, my view, having read everything from
Ben Graham one hundred years ago and understanding
what Warren Buffett's perspective is and the
great Jack Bogle and so on and so forth, my
view has always been, I don't think I can
time the market.
I don't think I'm slick enough.
I've got a full time job and understanding
that each year a huge portion of the gain
comes from a very small number of trading
days.
And if you're timing, you could miss one of
those days and miss out on a lot of the return
for a particular year, not to mention there
are tax implications to buying and selling,
et cetera.
Are there exceptions to that where it makes
sense to either try to time the market based
on the news cycle or legislatively or in any
other way?
I would generally say no, I would never try
to do something like that.
There are certain quantitative models that
use sort of a trend following to look looking
like 200 day moving averages and that.
But I don't want to get into all the technicalities
of that.
There are some that do and even those, like
a lot of those models which traditionally
work for the last twenty years, fail during
covid because it was such a quick decline
and it came back so quickly that quick would
be recovery that the models had never seen
anything like that.
And so they weren't they didn't have any data
to prepare for that to jump back in.
So you see a lot of people that actually the
best in the business, a trend following, got
a little bit burn this year, unfortunately,
but that's kind of that's what happens.
You know, it's just that's that's the nature
of markets.
So briefly, just talking about corporate tax
now, as we've been talking all about kind
of personal financial, there's this idea,
again, in the Biden tax plan of raising the
corporate income tax rate from twenty one
to twenty eight percent.
Now, a lot of small business owners, including
me, set up as an S corporation.
All of our income is passed through.
In other words, the business itself is paying
some STATT to quote Donald Trump, some statutory
amount, which I think in Massachusetts is
like four hundred and fifty dollars or something
like that.
And then basically I'm getting a K one as
an owner and I'm paying tax on my personal
income taxes.
So the corporate tax rate, I don't believe
actually affects me.
So it's kind of a two part question.
Are small businesses affected by the corporate
tax rate?
Who really is affected by that?
Yeah, so that's that.
And I mean, really, you're right, there's
a lot a lot of income, especially among, you
know, higher income families is coming through,
partner.
Ships and smaller businesses, not necessarily
corporate tax, is going to be for, I think,
much larger businesses, so it will affect
certain people.
But I think, as you said, a lot of people
have smaller businesses that you pass through
as a lot of law firms are pastors or partnerships,
things like that.
So it's going to affect some people and it'll
probably affect the stock market in some way
if that were to come to pass, because obviously
corporate tax means less profits.
So just simple as that.
So once again, this is how likely is this?
As of right now?
It doesn't seem too likely.
One of the things that's never made sense
to me, and I've asked a lot of economists
about this, you hear this talking point from
businesses.
If you raise the corporate tax rate, it will
be bad for the economy and it will be bad
in general because businesses won't invest
in growing their business.
To me, it seems completely counterintuitive
because if I'm a business owner and I can
take profits at a 20 percent tax rate or take
profits at a 30 percent tax rate, avoiding
a 30 percent tax seems like something I would
be more inclined to do.
And the way you avoid tax, of course, is by
making capital investment.
So if you apply a demand side approach, wouldn't
a higher corporate tax rate encourage investment
in a business because you're incentivized
to avoid what is a higher rate of tax?
Yeah, I mean, that's one way to look at it.
You can also say, like, OK, well, if my taxes
someone who doesn't want to go, do you want
you get it.
You want 70 cents.
You want 80 cents.
Like, oh, I'll take 70 cents here and give
it to me.
Right.
So you're still making money either way?
I do think the logic for that argument is
correct, but it has to be at a much higher
rate, I think going twenty one to twenty eight.
It's like, where are you on the curve?
That's always the question is, is the big
debate like if we went from obviously twenty
one to one hundred, you can see obviously
that that would completely devastate business
there.
But where is that.
How big is it measuring that?
That's really the crux of the argument.
And people argue on both sides.
And I think if it was clear, we would just
no way that we wouldn't be debating it.
That's the problem.
A lot of these debates, the reason our debates
is because it's not clear cut in the data
and it was clear cut.
We just wouldn't debate it anymore.
I think that's kind of how this works.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of I think there's a lot
of bad faith actors on both sides with these
issues that want to create edge cases that
nobody's arguing for.
Like, for example, people against the 15 dollar
minimum wage will often say, well, the fifteen's
better because people have more money.
What about one hundred and fifty?
And of course, nobody's talking about 150.
150 wouldn't be an equilibrium wage.
150 would not be a wage that's in line with
cost of living.
And I'm wondering if you also think that to
really discuss this stuff, we have to eliminate
these kind of strawman edge cases and think
about the meat of the curve as you're talking
about, not the extremes.
Yeah, I don't think you can use exceptions
to me to try and make rules are already rules.
It's really tough.
There are obviously, for example, one of the
biggest things in the investment literature
is this whole idea of the Black Swan.
It's like, oh, you look at this average distribution
and the exception is the most important thing
because the exception changes everything.
So I kind of agree with some of that logic
sometimes, but sometimes it's also a strawman.
When are you talking about or you talk about
in a risk context?
We're talking about in a minimum wage context,
obviously yallock.
Why not?
One hundred fifty?
Because that makes obviously no sense.
Like there's too many jobs where the equilibrium
wage is just far too low compared to one hundred
fifty an hour.
So I completely see both sides of it.
But yeah, I agree that you should try to like
where's the meat of the distribution.
I think it's a good way of looking at it.
We've been speaking with Nick Majilis, who
is CEO at Ritholtz Wealth Management, also
founder of Of Dollars and Data.
I might have missed one of the oves you're
founder of of Dollars and Data Debt Personal
Finance blog that I subscribe to.
Nick, really appreciate your time and having
you on.
Yes, thank you.
Appreciate it.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.